day 10 of the general election campaign  i'm here on london's pal mal where the  bosses meet at the iod their hedge  funders trade gentlemen clubs abound  quite the appropriate place to consider  the topic of the day soaking the rich or  likely bathing the super-rich all down  to this man King George the third George  the third created the non Dom system to  try and encourage colonialists to travel  abroad without fear of being taxed here  in Britain it's in jawed it's important  now for bankers and those hedge fund  traders today ed miliband said if he's  Prime Minister he'd scrap the whole  thing it got him good headlines in this  morning's paper it's great for his call  vote strategy but then the Conservatives  on earth of video of Ed Balls saying  that such a policy would cost money just  a few weeks ago and his message today  was there it would raise hundreds of  millions the numbers are uncertain the  politics clear a clear dividing line  between labor and the Conservatives